[Music]  you have no idea what's coming  mr. wit broke the rules  I trust you understand the repercussions  if he survives  John win X communicator is now  you shouldn't be here  nice soup good to see you too  I need your help after this we are less  than even  there's no escape for you the high table  wants your life  would you help set the mood frown you  guessed  let us begin our services still  off-limits to me what do you need  guns lots of guns you think you can take  John wick  you've got a nasty surprise coming  I've been looking forward to meeting you  all  for a long time  and so far you haven't disappointed  we can keep this up as long as you'd  like  but this only ends one way  [Music]  all of this for what because of a puppy  wasn't just a puppy  [Music]